hi hi
welcome to science Sangha i'm Sadashiva
pi from a science mission today we have
a dr. Vinita garden assistant professor
in physics from University of Texas
Austin is with us she has published
several public papers in peer-reviewed
journals
won several awards and is a member of
several societies and she has also
reviewed journals for several articles
for several journals so welcome dr.
garden thank you so can you please talk
about yourself tell about your
background education etc so I grew up in
Georgia I went to public schools in
Georgia and then into Vanderbilt
University which is in Tennessee and I
did a double major in physics and math
and I have up first in biology
whatsoever I wanted nothing to do and
then I went to graduate school at
University and I was going to do a PhD
in physics and I still wanted nothing to
do with biology I wanted to say in
biology as possible but then in my last
couple of years in graduate school I
started doing a project that was looking
at a human brain cancer and saying what
is this brain cancer doing to the
environment this end how is it impacting
the inverter its environment which in
our case was just a job that we used but
for a real brain tumor will be the
person's brain it was growing in and I
didn't want to do biology still but I
liked the feeling that I got from that
project that I could see how it could
really matter to people and that was a
feeling feeling to me but it still
wasn't enough to make me want to do
biology and then I went into the postdoc
and then when I was trying to figure out
what to do for my second postdoc I was
looking at a lot of possibilities and I
was looking at a lot of very good
scientists and the only people I felt
excited to work with the were the people
who were doing something to do with
biology some sort of biophysics work
and I was very real off to this I didn't
want to do anything with biology I
thought it was too messy and too
complicated and not pricing clean the
way I was used to physics but I
eventually said if you're not excited to
do a postdoc then there's no point in
doing a postdoc so I did a postdoc if
they got me more into biology and then
as I've been in a faculty position I've
made even more to biology okay and other
than I know you are very busy with all
the biggest and professor unit write
grants get money and take care of the
lab and all so do you get some time to
do other things other than research um
what do you mean other than research
like give me like in my personal life
you know I mean like yeah like you have
any hobbies or anything like that
we have a three year old and a five year
old so I don't like hobbies I have two
children okay when I'm not doing stuff
with my kids I like to read for fun now
before I had children I like to sing in
choirs and I like to go hiking and my
kids are just getting old enough that I
can start to take them on short hikes
okay a little bit of stuff like that and
I used to like to go swimming and
they're just getting old enough we can
do that but my kids sort of took over
overall my hobby space for a while okay
and let's talk about your lab lab people
and also tell me about your people in
the lab so how do you manage them how do
you motivate them so I try to pick
people who were really interested in
doing science and then I try to match
them to projects that I think are a good
match for their interests and their
Vanda but I guess I feel at the end of
the day it's not my job to motivate
people it's my job to provide a good
environment and to provide like good
support when they need support which can
mean I could support them by encouraging
them if that's what they need or I can
support them by saying what you're doing
is really not okay and you have to be
better because that's the type of that
kind of criticism is a type of support
as well but at the end of the day the
motivation is their response
ability like you say I don't feel
motivated I feel like well figure out
what you have to do to get yourself
motivated this is not my job I don't own
your motivation okay and like can you
please talk about some of the research
projects you are doing and then we can
move on to the you can just lead us to
the presentation okay most of my
research focuses on bacterial biofilms
and we try to understand better your
biofilms are when you have communities
of bacteria that are adhered to each
other and often to other things in their
environment because they're encased in a
matrix of polymer and protein and we're
trying to understand how physical
properties of the biofilm arise and how
those physical properties might matter
in disease or some real-world
application and we're trying to
understand how physical properties of
the environment in which the bacteria
are growing could matter for a biofilm
in some way okay and can we like talk
about your presentation like why don't
you go ahead and present your work okay
okay can you see it now okay so I call
them calling this bacterial McKenna
biology because rather than talk about
everything that we do I thought that
just mainly to focus on one project and
there's a projects that are out there
that are published that people can read
if they're interested but so a biofilm
as I just told you our communities of
bacteria and they're embedded and a
matrix of polymer and protein that they
create so this picture that you see here
has these rod shaped bacteria and then
you see this sort of darker green
stringy stuff this is a scanning
electron microscope of a biofilm and
it's been dried out so they could do the
SEM on it
but in a real biofilm the stringy stuff
will be the polymer and the whole thing
would be well hydrated and the bacteria
will be growing in this matrix bacterial
biofilms are problem in medicine because
when a bacteria makes the transition and
it's now in the biofilm state it becomes
much more resistant to antibiotics and
much more resistant to the immune system
and this is independent of any genetic
mechanisms of antibiotic resistance that
might have so you could have the same
genetic organism that would be
vulnerable to antibiotics at when it was
just a free-swimming bacterium but it
would be able to resist antibiotics when
it was in the biofilm State so that's a
problem there also a problem outside the
body so when they're in industry like on
oil pipes they can corrode the oil pipe
and make it leak or they can make the
transport of oil less efficient they can
grow in water filtration and delivery
systems which can be a problem that
reduces it reduces the efficiency of the
water treatment and then it can also
potentially dose people with pathogenic
bacteria if they show up so we hear
about these biofilms in terms of
creating problems we don't spend a lot
of time in my group thinking about good
acid
so biofilms but I think for the sake of
honesty and completeness I will say that
there are ways that biofilms can be
beneficial
people are looking biofilms as a way to
do bioremediation so if there's some
pollutant and the environment can use
the bacteria to eat it and clear it up
and make it something that's not harmful
and people are thinking about biofilms
is a way to produce biological products
so we don't focus on that very much at
all in my group but that is out there
and there are other people thinking
about it so my background is in physics
my degrees are all in physics and my
appointment is in a physics department
and so you might ask why am i studying
biofilms in the physics department which
is a fair question because most biofilm
research is done in microbiology
departments that makes perfect sense but
the answer is that these biofilms have
physical characteristics that are very
different from the free-swimming
bacteria that are suspended in fluid and
those physical characteristics linked
tightly to some of the unique properties
of biofilms those physical
characteristics comes from the fact that
these bacteria are embedded in a matrix
and what that does for the bacteria is
it gives them mechanical forces that
adhere them to each other and it here
them to a surface and it gives the whole
biofilm a mechanical property and by
sticking the bacteria in a together with
an adhesion it gives the bacteria
spatial structure in their arrangement
and we study how both of these things
impact biofilms in my group I'm only
going to focus today on these mechanical
properties and I'm not even going to do
I'm not going to tell you everything we
do with mechanical properties for lack
of time I'm just going to tell you about
our most recent project but if you're
interested in hearing more of what we've
done you can go find the publications on
our website okay so I'm going to start
off with how biofilms are initiated and
how bacteria know they're on a surface
so this is what's called the canonical
life cycle for a biofilm this is how
everybody has thought about how biofilms
worked for a long time so you start
these free-swimming cells which are also
called planktonic cells like plankton in
the ocean they attach to the surface
when they attach to the surface they
somehow since that they're on a surface
and they produce internal signals that
change their gene expression and one of
the things that change in gene
expression does is they start making
more of these extracellular polymers
that stick the bacteria more firmly to
the surface and they stick them to each
other and then they grow and they make
more polymers and the biomass
accumulates until eventually there's a
dispersion of bacteria again now I have
a lot of issues with a lot of things
that are shown in this canonical model
but we're not going to talk about all
the issues I have we're going to focus
right now on this very first step where
the bacteria attach to the surface and
somehow become aware that they're on a
surface and this is an important stage
of biofilm development to study because
if you can understand what triggers
bacteria to make the transition from
planktonic to by a cone phenotype then
you can think about what could you do to
prevent that transition and prevent the
biofilm from getting started in the
first place so it's been known for a
long time that attachment to the surface
triggered biofilm development and it's
kind of intrinsically obvious that if
you go from being suspended and fluid to
being attached to a surface this will
change the mechanical environment that's
experienced by the bacteria and one of
the things that this can change in a
really radical way is that it can
increase the shear to which the bacteria
are subject that can be the case if the
fluid is flowing so if the fluid is
flowing in the bacteria is suspended in
the media
tonight if the Hangout just tripped out
on me the webpage crash do you have me
again yeah okay so if the medium is
flowing and the bacteria are freely
suspended in the medium do you have my
web page are my presentation the
presentation is still there okay yeah I
don't know what happened there okay um
then the the medium will just carry the
bacteria along and I'll essentially not
feel any shear stress but once they
adhere to the surface part of the
bacteria is stuck on the surface and
that's going to resist displacement and
the other side of the bacteria is going
to be being pulled on by the flowing
medium so that's going to give us year
and another way it can experience share
is if it's trying to move on the surface
there's species of bacteria that can
move on the surface and if they're
moving on the surface by these adhesion
by these little peel I but they're stuck
because they have adhesion to the
surface then those high if they drag
them forward are going to result in this
fear and feeling a shear force because
this side is resisting displacement and
this side is not so what we want to know
is yes okay these facts are all kind of
intrinsically obvious but does it matter
for the biofilm development are these
two sort of yes these are true but the
bacteria don't care that's what we're
going after and what I'm going to talk
about today so it's been known for a
long time that eukaryotic cells but the
cells in our body respond to forces and
mechanics and here I'm showing three
review articles I could have filled up a
bazillion slides with review articles
alone on this topic and there are many
many more articles in the primary
literature so this is just to give you a
feeling that everybody knows that
mechanics matter for eukaryotic cells
and mechanobiology is an important large
and growing field but much much less is
known about how much the mechanics
matter for bacteria so we're going to
start at the very beginning
this is for us a shot from a movie
called The Sound of Music where this
lady is singing a song and it starts off
let's start at the very beginning so
we're going to start at the very
beginning of a bio film and we're going
to ask two questions what are the
factors that determine the mechanical
and geometric coupling of bacteria to
the surface and can we associate a
response to shear stress with these
mechanical and geometric couplings and
our model organism it's going to be
Pseudomonas aeruginosa this is a picture
of it it readily forms biofilms and its
forms biofilms that have important
effects on human disease which include
cystic fibrosis diabetes and chronic
obstructive pulmonary disease but also
its eminent on medical devices and the
strain of Pseudomonas that I'm going to
tell you about today makes two different
extracellular polysaccharides these are
these polymers that stick the bacteria
down to a surface and kind of scaffold
the matrix in the biofilm as it grows
the names of these polysaccharides are
PSL and pel and here I'm showing you one
repeat unit for PSL so this would repeat
however many times because it's a
polymer I'm showing you the two main
constituents of pel but the molecular
structure of pel is it none these are
two partially Isetta lated amino sugars
and how they are strung together to make
the pel repeat unit hasn't been
determined in fact the fact that these
were the two main constituents of pel
was only determined fairly recently like
that paper was published in 2015 by Matt
parsec strip at University of Washington
so we can use microscopy to examine how
bacteria interact with the surface and
we're going to start off by doing this
using phase contrast microscopy and
we're going to use a wild type bacterium
which is abbreviated W T and this makes
both PS LM pal and that's what you see
in this movie and we're going to use
some knockouts that don't make specific
polymers this one doesn't make pal this
one doesn't make PS L and this one
doesn't make either PS l our pal and we
can take movies of these bacteria on the
surface and then we can
software code to track and analyze what
these bacteria are doing and we can
analyze different aspects of their
behavior on the surface so when we did
this we found that the bacteria that
were on the surface that were the
wild-type that may both PSL ml stayed on
the surface for essentially their whole
lifetime that's what you're seeing here
that's what we're measuring is
normalized dwell time we're dwell time
is the time on the surface and
normalized ones means we've normalized
it to the average bacterial life time so
this distribution is centered on one and
these bacteria do a great job of staying
on the surface if you knock out pal
which is the dashed blue line these
bacteria also do a great job of staying
on the surface they make PSL and that's
good enough for this them to stay on the
surface for their whole lifetime if you
knock out PSL that's the dotted yellow
line you see that about half the
bacteria stay on the surface for their
whole lifetime and about half of them
detached from the surface very shortly
after the cell divides and when you look
at a double knockout that doesn't make
either PSL our pal
then you see that almost none of this
bacteria stay on the surface for very
long at all that's what you see in this
movie where these bacteria hop on the
surface and then hop off again but we
get out of this is that PSL strongly
promotes permanent adhesion to the
surface and as long as you make PSL you
don't need to make pedal to stick to the
surface you just find in terms of seen
on the surface but there's something
else that pal does we can look at the
aspect ratio of these bacteria so we
have our microscope lens down here and
when you look up at these bacteria as
they're projected on the focal plane of
the microscope objective and by looking
at their projected aspect ratio we can
see whether they're lying down flat or
they're tilted up because tilting up
will make them appear artificially
shorter we know that wild type inductive
he'll have the same geometric aspect
ratio because we measured this by hand
but when we look at the projected aspect
ratio of wild-type versus Delta pel we
see that the delta pel histogram is
shifted over to the left to two smaller
aspect ratios and it has this shoulder
which is not apparent for the wildtype
so we know that the delta pell bacteria
spend a lot more time tilting up off the
surface attached to only one end so we
were curious about what was going on to
change that form of attachment and we to
measure the forces that were causing the
bacteria to interact with the surface we
attached bacteria to the tip of an
atomic force microscope cantilever and
we brought them in contact with the
surface and then we pulled them away
again and we measured the force
displacement curves associated with
pulling bacteria off the surface so this
in red is a typical force displacement
curve the wild type and this in blue is
a typical force displacement curve for
the Delta pel and what we see is that
the wild type force displacement curve
is it's well localized there's a
well-defined peak force and it's it's
it's here basically where as with the
Delta pel knock out so only PSL is
acting to promote adhesion here the
force isn't so well localized there's
not that well-defined peak that you get
for a wild type and we did this about a
hundred times for each type of bacteria
and what we find is that the peak force
required to pull the bacteria off that's
the height of this curve at its maximum
value is a little bit higher for wild
type than it is for Delta pel but the
distance over which that force can
extend the range of interaction of the
bacteria with a surface is much greater
for Delta pelvin it is for wild type and
you see this right here so if you want
to think about the energy cost to pull a
bacterium off the surface you can
integrate under these curves so you're
integrating force as a function of this
distance and that gives you work and
what we find is that the work required
to detach the bacteria from the surface
is much less for the wild type than it
is for the Delta pal so that means that
these bacteria are making pal and yet it
actually decreases the work of
detachment so we're wondering what's the
advantage to making pal why would you
pay the metabolic cost to maintain this
gene and make this the gene product when
the acts to decrease the work of
detachment
so one thing that pal seems to do which
could be a benefit to the bacteria is it
makes the distribution of PSL on the
surface of the bacteria more symmetric
these are images of bacteria that we
took using a form of microscopy that
gives us higher spatial resolution and
we dyed these bacteria using the
antibody for PSL and what we find is for
the wild-type the distribution of PSL on
the surface is much more symmetric than
it is for the Delta health and we can
quantify that by cutting each image
bacteria in half and taking the ratio of
the brightness of the bright half to the
dimmer half and the bigger the bigger
that ratio is a further away from one
the more asymmetric the distribution of
PSL is on the surface and that's what
you see in this plot so PSL helps to
make the back to the bacteria more
sticky all over by making PSL
distributed all over their surface and
that could be a big part of how they
help the bacteria to lie down flat but
that doesn't say how is lying down flat
advantageous for these bacteria and is
there an advantage to the particular
form of the force displacement curve
that we solve for wild-type bacteria so
remember we started talking I started
off this talk talking about surface
sensing okay
so one question we could ask is this
making pal and changing the form of the
attachment and changing the tightness of
the mechanical coupling to the surface
does that impact surface sensing somehow
so for Pseudomonas aeruginosa and for a
lot of other bacteria cyclic die GMP is
an intracellular Molecular signal that's
very important for controlling biofilm
initiation and for Pseudomonas
aeruginosa cyclic die GMP is activated
when the bacteria attached to a surface
and the levels of cyclic GMP inside the
cells go up and this controls the change
of expression of a lot of genes since
the bacteria switch from a beam in a
planktonic state to being in a biofilm
state in fact if you somehow prevents
the bacteria from having large amounts
of PS of cyclic IgM
be inside them they won't make the
transition to a biofilm so this is a key
step in biofilm initiation and this has
been known for a while it's been
established by other groups but what
hasn't been known is how to bacteria
since the surface what is their cue that
they're on a surface and remember
bacteria don't have eyes like I can do
I'm on a surface by looking down at my
feet and saying oh I'm standing on the
floor but they don't have that what do
they do to know they're on a surface so
we're going to probe this using the same
sort of genetic knockouts we talked
about before but now we're going to use
bacteria that contain a reporter that
makes forests and proteins when they
have higher amounts of cyclic GMP so the
brighter the bacteria are the more
cyclic GMP they contain and we're going
to image these using a technique called
codes local microscopy that allows us to
get better resolution of the bacterial
brightness and we're going to do this in
a microscope that's enclosed in
incubator chamber and this is important
because it lets us do all our
experiments at physiological temperature
without having to take the bacteria on
the microscope and then put them in an
incubator and move them back and forth
and this allows us to do continual
measurements so that we can see what the
cyclic GMP time course is like whereas
previous work would sort of measure
cyclic GMP levels they would give some
input or some treatment to the bacteria
they would wait several hours and then
they would measure the endpoint so this
is presents a new capability for cyclic
GMP measurement when we do this if we
compare the wild-type bacteria to Delta
pel bacteria we see that in the first 30
minutes after attaching to the surface
the wild-type and the Delta pel bacteria
their populations look identical in
terms of their cyclic IGMP brightness
but after about half an hour attached to
the surface the wild-type population has
more bright bacteria and they say break
for longer before they start to dim
again and if you don't want to look at
all these histograms you can just
average each 30-minute histogram to one
point and that's what we have here so
this is showing wild-type in red and
Delta pel in blue they start off with
ident
Cole average brightnesses but then the
wild type populations become brighter
and that brightness is longer-lived
than it is for the Delta pel bacteria so
this shows a way that making pal could
be advantageous for sensing a surface
but it doesn't say why it's advantageous
so let's explore possibilities for why
this could be different for wild-type
and Delta pal so remember a while back I
showed you force displacement curves and
we showed that the wild-type had this
very steep curve near the surface in
this very well localized for speak but
near the surface the Delta pel had a
more shallow curve and the forced peak
wasn't so well localized well we know
that these bacteria use PLI these are
little hairlike appendages that act like
grappling hooks to reach out and grab
the surface and pull the bacteria
forward and we can use microscopy and
care sorry um we can use microscopy to
measure the speeds of the bacteria on
the surface and we see that the
wild-type are slower than the Delta pel
and we can average all these speeds
together for all these different
bacteria and we see that the wild-type
and the Delta Pal are really
significantly different in terms of
their speeds and this is likely because
pail increases friction with the surface
and that makes sense if you look at
these force displacement curves because
this force displacement curve for
wild-type is steeper than the force
displacement curve for Delta Pal meaning
that to achieve the same displacement
the same kind of movement along the
surface you would have to exert more
force for the wild-type than you would
for the Delta L and we also see that
these differences in speed depend on how
much of this cells life time it spends
tilting up off the surface so when the
cells spend about half or more of their
life time tilting up off the serpent's
there's no significant difference in the
speeds of the two strains of bacteria
but as the cells spend more time lying
down flat on the surface we see that the
wild-type becomes significantly slower
than the Delta
and it's not that the Delta pel is
getting faster is that the wildtype is
becoming more slow because this is going
down as you go toward lower values on
the x-axis so this suggests that it
might be sheer arising from bacterial
motility that's causing the wild-type to
sense the surface so if that's true we
got to be able to test that by applying
an external shear to these bacteria and
we're going to do this using a flow cell
system this is a very standard system
for culturing biofilms it's used widely
in microbiology and because we know the
dimensions of the flow cell and we and
we can control the rate of fluid flow we
can control the shear on the bacteria
and when we do this we're going to take
as our measurement these three time
points right here we're going to take
the time points at these Peaks and
average them all together so this is
going to be a measure of the average
peak response for the wild-type in the
Delta Pal bacteria as a function of
shear stress and when we do that we find
that as we increase shear both wild-type
and Delta pel have an increase to quit
die GMP production this is important
because it allows us to distinguish the
generation of stress from the sensing of
stress and we see that these are
responding in lockstep with each other
so the sensing of mechanical stress
isn't impaired in Delta Cal but they're
because they're mechanical coupling to
the surface is weaker they don't feel as
much stress and so they're they don't
respond as strongly and we see that if
we so we can measure the time course of
cyclic GMP signaling under these under
shear stress as well and when we do this
we see this is the time course without
any external shear so only what the
bacteria provides are their own motility
and blue is the tiny course for bacteria
that are under constant external shear
and if we start off with no external
shear and then we activate it at this
time we can reactivate cyclic IGMP
signaling and this suggests that that
bacteria may have a way to distinguish
responding to surface adhesion from a
response to external shear and then we
tried we wanted to know what
important for the bacteria to be able to
sense shear and know they're on a
surface so we tried strains of bacteria
where we knocked out different proteins
and we knocked out a protein called pill
y1 we docked on a protein called pill a
which is what is used to make the pee
lie and we not part of the pious motor
pill tees so that these bacteria aren't
able to pull their pee light back and in
every case we see that these bacteria
don't respond to the surface and they
don't respond to shear stress so
something about these elements is
important as part of the mechana
censoring process or as part of the
signaling cascade that follows that this
is interesting in terms of pill y1
because pill y1 this protein that we
that we knocked out right here which is
an important for this signaling process
has a weak resemblance to the von
Willebrand factor a domain and the von
Willebrand factor a domain is a Meccano
responsive domain that's very widespread
in higher eukaryotes like us and it was
first characterized and has been best
characterized in terms of blood clotting
and what the one Willebrand factor
domain does is it senses changes from
shear stress to elongational stress and
when a film elongational stress it
unzips and it exposes lots of sticky
domains for platelets to stick to to
promote blood clotting so this is
somewhat consistent with the idea of
kauai one being a Meccano sensor and
people have seen before us that pill y1
was associated with surface behaviour
now earlier I showed you some review
articles and I told you I could have
filled tons of papers with review
articles alone let alone the primary
literature now I'm only showing you
primary literature articles associating
po y 1 with surface behaviors and I
don't have any more to show you this is
it this is the complete primary
literature so people have explored Kawai
1 as an actor on surfaces before but
this is still a very new idea and the
idea of bacteria responding
signalling response to shear stress is
new to our work so then we can approach
this and say can we use some
mathematical modeling to get better
insight into what's going on here and
when we do this we're going to set up
some governing equations so we're going
to say that the change and cyclic GMP
with time is going to depend on the
number of activated surface sensors and
the force applied to them and there's
going to be a constituent of degradation
rate that cyclic die GMP doesn't just
want to go up and stay high and there's
going to be a constituent of production
rate so the activation of force sensors
is also going to depend on how much
cyclic die GMP is there and it's going
to depend on how much EPS is present and
the production rate of EPS and there's
going to be an intrinsic degradation or
decay of activated Force sensors and
because we know the cyclic die GMP
increases the production of EPS we have
a feedback loop saying that when cyclic
die GMP is higher you'll have more
production of EPS through this coupling
factor alpha 4 and then as the bacteria
move around on the surface some of the
EPS will be lost and deposited on the
surface so this is a decay rate
the website just crashed again do you
have me yeah have I have you I think
dis changing Wow okay alright I don't
know why it just crash again okay so
when we go into this model we're making
some assumptions one is that the
wildtype adhere more strongly to a
surface and therefore they have more
sensor proteins this y one that are
activated meaning they're in contact
with a surface and so we're going to
start off with these initial values
which are based on geometric factors the
size of the protein the number of
proteins that are going to be in the
cell and how much of the cells are known
to be lying down on the surface and when
we do this we can fit our model
equations that's these continuous lines
right here to achieve good reproduction
of the values for both wild type and
delta pel and then we can go into our
model and we can change the external
stress that's being applied by changing
this constant alpha one and when we do
that using the same parameters we used
here and now just playing around and
changing alpha one we can change we can
get fits to the high shear stress and to
that this continuous shear stress where
you start off with no shear and then you
activate it and all of these achieve a
good description of what we've measured
experimentally and that's showing what
these alpha 1 values are if there's zero
shear stress or if there's some shear
stress applied externally and then we
just by hand activate it right here for
the curves in black then we have all
these parameters that have been scented
this way and we're going to keep all the
parameters constant except for alpha one
in very only alpha one for the wild type
and by varying alpha one to fit these
curves to the data for wild type then
we're able to make a set of predictive
curves for delta pel that are purely
predictive so these are not fits they're
just plots of the curves that we got
using these alpha 1 values which were
retained for while
and they do a really good job of
describing the data for zero external
shear and for high external shear
they're not great for these intermediate
values but they're also not terrible and
the curves have the right shape and the
trends are in the right direction
so this looks like a reasonably good
model so while we've shown here has some
implications for how it might tie in to
the broader literature there's been a
thing that's not have been known about
biofilms for a while that vaio folks
that are grown under high shear are
stiffer meaning they have a higher
elastic modulus and they're more dense
in polymers and proteins than our
biofilms grown under low shear and we've
just shown that shear can activate
cyclic IGMP signaling so one of our
questions is is this why is higher
cyclic GMP signaling which activates
higher production of matrix polymers and
proteins the reason that you see changes
and biofilm mechanical properties
associated with their their growth
conditions under different shear rates
another thing we've seen that's new is
tied in to the non monotonic form of the
cyclic GMP signaling where first it goes
up upon attachment to the surface and
then it goes back down again
no-one's measured this sort of cyclic
GMP time course before and so we don't
know what aspects of these this time
course are important for biofilm
development and the fact that it goes up
and then goes back down again suggests
that this may act as a toggle switch
such that these high values right here
may be what's important for sending the
bacteria to a biofilm state and then you
don't have to maintain those high values
because the bacteria is already set to
be in a biofilm State and this sort of
toggle switch to mechana sensing states
have been seen for higher eukaryotic
cells and this is something we're
interested in exploring in the future
and we're interested in knowing if we
manipulate the mechanical properties of
the surface that the bacteria is
attached to so that it doesn't feel as
much mechanical resistance from the
surface can we suppress cyclic GMP
signaling
so the bacteria don't do as good a job
of knowing they're on the surface and
they don't do as good a job of
transitioning into a biofilm that's
something we're working on in my group
right now and the early results look
very promising I'll sit back so the
conclusion I want to get out of this is
that evolution has decided that very
tight geometric and mechanical coupling
to the surface is a good idea that
mechanics encino sheer stress activates
the emission of biofilms and we have a
secret Envy for engineers because we
want to learn how to build surfaces that
do cool things and that is all I have to
say for this presentation I would like
if I can to skip ah to my
acknowledgments slide and I like to
thank the people who did the work on
this so thank you for having me big part
of this hangout Thank You PJ Cooley a
hip hop baby too big a Cooley who is now
at University of Georgia who published
these two papers making a chrismad Oh
Chris Roe doesn't even did the mechana
sensing work um this is under review at
pas that this was actually recently
published in PNAS and then there's some
other work that tie into bacterial
mechanics when they're already in a
biofilm state which I didn't talk about
today for a lack of time but that was
published and the npj by iPhones and
microbiome journal that's an open access
journal so everyone should be able to
get this and this is also open access so
everyone should be able to get this
these are not open access but if people
send me emails I can send you PDFs with
these papers and there were people who
work with us on different instruments
and give us access to different
bacterial strains and these were all
super helpful to us so I'm gonna stop
sharing this now okay if I can figure
out how double-click on that uh left
arrow yeah oh here you go yeah okay yeah
it's a pretty nice talk thank you very
much for taking time to come to hangout
and give your presentation it's really I
think yeah really showed us how physics
can like you can do biology not but
learn
more about biology and that is really
useful in fact in in terms of the
medical field well especially in the
hospital central where you don't want to
have this kind of bacteria on the
surface how do you basically prevent it
and some of your work is been pretty
interesting I have a question like you
you're talking about PSL and PLL and all
those things are there any other
saccharides which are being exploited to
support this matrix there can be so the
strain that I showed you was a lab
strain that only makes PS LM Pell and
that's nice for us because it's
genetically well characterized and we
can manipulate the genetics and
well-defined ways like you saw on the
talk but lab strains can have other
things they produce the main other
polysaccharide that on that clinical
isolates and some lab strains can make
is something called alginate and we
didn't go into alginate for this work
because we were the focus of this wasn't
really on the polysaccharides it was
what are they sensing and the
polysaccharides were just a a nice tool
that we could use to tune the strength
of the coupling to the surface but in
other work we've measured what the
mechanics of a whole biofilm is like and
we've shown that PSL and pail and
alginate I'll have very different
effects from each other for fur lab
strains but also for clinical isolates
that were taken from the lungs of
patients and is that does cyclic die GMP
is the only signal you see are like is
there any other calcium or anything else
happens there that's the only one we
probed because that's been shown to be
so essential for biofilm initiation
there are other things associated with
biofilms especially a little bit later
in the course of biofilm development
where intracellular signaling is known
to be important but we were looking at a
time very early in biofilm development
where I wouldn't have expected that to
kick him okay I think again thank you so
much for taking time to join us and I
really appreciate it and good luck with
your future work and if you think there
is something new you want to share
shoot men email so you can do another
hangout sometime in the future all right
sounds great thank you so much all right
you